große liebe einfach kein haus mehr ich
bin gewohnt einfach hier mitten auf
seinem grundstück so eine scheiße tür
stehen ja ich habe auch gestern gelüftet
weiß doch was ist das was da hin zum
schweben bringt das ist ein aufzug den
hub kann man sich weil formcraft
anbietet er zaubert sage ich mal
ich kann nicht zaubern hast du noch mehr
kisten oder nur die darum stehen
wie meinst dass ich hab auch noch welche
im keller juli mit da sind auch noch
drei glasscheiben dass fast kein platz
so plan b leute ich versuche jetzt das
schnell einfach einzusetzen
so jetzt aber ja ich habe es geschafft
für das hier sehen könnt ist was ich
mache nur beim blöden nein ich suche ja
alles was so durchsucht
auch schon gesagt die weinglas aus
youtube meter ich schaue man sollte
gehen auf jeden fall
ja und zwar ich habe eine idee crafting
table kräftig table kräften table ist
haye läuft bei dir ein bisschen aber
richtig bei mir wenn du das hier sehen
könnt ist nur dein haus sehen können das
alter schöner als hier zuvor und freue
mich jetzt schon drauf
solltest du auf das war falsch
wahrscheinlich doch nicht so schön dass
er sich von schön mit glas zumindest
sieht schön aus und firma herr von firma
hat er einfach super glaswerke kaputt
gemacht ja einfach so na also erdacht
halt dass ich bei ihm dann ist also drei
centertools in sein haus gestellt habe
und dass ich sein haus in obsidian
verwandelt habe was ich gemacht habe
diese elende gelte einmal auch mit der
politik an rund um ein grundstück sind
auch bei der portal gun also wenn man ja
damit auf den skis da sind solche gräben
bei mir rund um ein kunststück
ich kenne ihn nur zu gut portugal und
unten hat er auch oben was kaputt
gemacht oben glaube ich nicht schaut
trotzdem sicherheitshalber man ruhig mal
etwas schneller als der sand und da
kommt der sand hui neonazis ich hab' ich
geschafft oder ich hab es ja auch
geschafft dass auch einen steinblock
nein aber nicht ehrlich noch einen
steinblock weiter
probier mal glück kannst du dich mit der
portal dann einfach wegnehmen wenn ich
da hoch kommen sollte dann schon ich war
hab das eben gerade immer mit der
portugal gemacht weil ich schließe mich
mal hoch falls noch mehrere okay von
unten sah es aus wie ein stein
das sind wirklich mehrere private ist
aber kein problem weil ich jetzt darum
porte ihn gemacht habe und achtung
ich brauch jetzt schnell mal koppel denn
wenn ich da gleich runter fliege mache
ich so jetzt aber nicht geschafft schade
das schaffst du nie im leben alter habe
ich schon eben geschafft und jetzt pass
auf jetzt kommt der tag da stehe ich
disco day
ok ich schaue mal ob ich wieder strom
bekommen die eigentlich gar nicht sein
nach gerade das komitee seine du bist
krank und du hast einfach dann nicht nur
nase schmerz sondern auf einer kompakten
schmerzen dazu und alles einfach klingt
dann aber wirklich eindeutig die
erkältung von einem offenen fenster kam
das irgendwie so zu bekommen keine
ahnung ob du vorher noch trainiert hast
du also habe ich sogar an dies das
bekommt man das geld um den verstand den
weg zu ende zu sehen und komme doch zu
kommen
so soll ihre schmerzenden nacken mein
nacken tut wieder weh
ja was machen sie in ihrer freizeit ja
ich direkt am computer saß
dies darf sie haben aids und ehrlich
sind weg will ich das mal bitte kurz
pennen gehn alles klar meister dann kann
ich guck mal wie viel strom bekommen
du hast ja auch so eine tötung style auf
dem grundstück stehen normaler spurt bei
mir
ach mein keller muss ich auch nochmal
jemand fed besprochen dass ich lass mich
mal eben schon hier auf vor
ich finde die ladestation richtig geilen
damit den von der stadt da würde ich
noch lampen hinsetzt und alles und mach
ich glaub ich nämlich lamm aus dem
keller erst mal raus und setzt sich dann
nachher bei mir auf links komm lass pen
kollege und hat den deckel
ich bin auf dem weg allein das sind doch
jetzt das shoppen gehen der monster
ja er ist tot schlicke im bettchen und
letztlich in der nase putzen ganzen
einschlafen die musik die stört mich ein
wenig im hintergrund läuft
meine nase so also kommt energie an die
80.000 chilis war echten gemeiner troja
mails raider ist wieder voll
der braucht bestimmt ewigkeiten dass man
erstmals direkt voll alter stein habe
ich scheine ja so was auf na gut stimmt
das geht schon relativ schnell machte
recht wofür brauche ich noch mal koppel
den weg denn wir müssen jetzt erstmal
langsam was so richtig soziales machen
so richtig was los
ja ich werde ich bin ja hier schon bei
der aber ihren weg bahnt ja habe ich
hoch
hohoho rieckmann eigene truhe von dir
hier in die eisen ton ein bisschen sand
passt auf jeden fall war es für später
ja ich habe jetzt eh schon genug glas
und so okay ich hab jetzt komm ich
lieben stacks glas oder so weil ich mir
das einfach alles mit dir für dein
grundstück gemacht habe ich brauche auf
jeden fall noch eine menge szenen die
man schnell repariert ja habe ich
korrekt danke also sollte eigentlich
korrekt sein also noch korrigiert
korrekt korrigiert korrekt ihre day
korrekt irrt normal so da bin ich mal
gespannt
ich hoffe es ist ist es wunderbar ich
habe nix neues kleidchen hab das einfach
nur besser reparierten standing danke
für den steinen austausch wir sind so
sozial wir dachten soziale folgen machen
wir uns gegenseitig das ist doch auch
sozial oder einer gewissen feiern eine
selbstverständliche eine hand wäscht die
andere
normal so jetzt auch immer noch die
pilze ufern von simon moore krass naja
ich lasse es menschlich
ich bin jetzt in meiner mode falle wie
viele uncharted bücher wir hier haben
kann ich nicht hier einfach mal so dass
hier endlich ein paar schweine sport
sport sport wenn du irgendwie ein paar
schweine brauchst dann sagt dann bringe
ich die reben eines bonner vorbei ich
brauche eigentlich mehr solarpanels ich
glaube ich habe mich darum kümmern dass
ich mehr solarpanels mache dann werde
ich mit spark aufnehmen die us bank hat
ja seine produktion
jan ich hab ich schon selber steht was
hier im blog erinnerung an die erste
bomben zerstörung haha ja es ist ein
grundstein und den kann mir niemand
kaputten niemand da geht dann nicht mehr
weg das ist ein betrag der bett lag
deswegen habe ich denn da hingestellt
weil er einfach nicht durch den ju
kaputtgeht alt hat selbst ein heftiges
links hier
das ding ist ein grundstück das lässt da
nicht das baut da nicht mit der hand auf
ich habe das so mitbekommen der bau das
oder lässt das von den turtles aufbauen
automatisches voll krass das ist heftig
aber ich habe jetzt noch richtig viel
vor hat ja auch hier ein wasserkraftwerk
ja wenn man sich da im vergleich marie
wiesengrundstück daneben anguckt wie
sauce im leben einfach kein haus mehr in
der wohnung gewohnt einfach hier mitten
auf seinem grundstück so ein scheiß tür
stehen ja ich habe auch gestern gelüftet
weißt du doch
es soll keiner ist auf brasilien wartet
das muss natürlich mal eben schnell
beheben
kobil mhh reviers grund ist einfach mal
so verhalte wie viele ob sie denn er ja
das muss ich alles mal wieder weghauen
ich fresse von ihrem kuchen so ein
bisschen nicht selbst dahin gestellt
habe er hält es so klar dass der pinke
wolle einfach hatte er hat so viele
mieter sondern es mich weiterbringt
wolle weil sie nicht guck mal ich glaube
eher camping gewonnen aber kommt lege
ich mal wieder eine tour einsatz ab sie
wird allgemein richtig viele sachen
sicher schnorr hier ja denn ich selbst
wie man opfer höhe weiter die ganzen
generatoren krass wir müssen jetzt
wollen erstmal hier den weg vielleicht
ein bisschen schöner bauen hier so bei
denen hier weil das ist relativ einfach
wo bist du gerade komm zu mir hey
welchem grundstück bist du bei die
bieter oder cad pedro okay und ich will
schnell wieder ja dass du das hier
erstmals down down und dann mit schüssel
stone briggs normalerweise in die mitte
kommt ja normaler koppel war ja nicht es
geht auch mit dem top viel besser ach so
ja da macht einen kleinen weg wirklich
genügend koppeln ich habe ein halbes
deck
danke auch noch bei dir im base rate
glaube ich komme dann fliegen wir mehr
richtig was ich mache meinen portal
intakt was andere kontaktieren und sich
eh schon noch bei dir sein ich bin
schneller als du who wo man könnte auch
beim wettrennen irgendwie durch die
stadt hier machen aber dann braucht
jeder eine quanz umrüstung eigentlich ja
natürlich ich muss mich auch nochmal
eine setzen aber das mache ich alles
dann irgendwie eventuell dann bei einem
live stream oder irgendwie sowas sondern
keine ahnung
kommen sie mit junger mann ja ich hole
meine schüssel scheiße hier ja ich hab
noch ganz viel kosten für dich by the
way geil so noch 26 schüsse aus denn für
mich für die stadt
natürlich ist allgemeinwohl für den
start der server wo besteht sondern
müssen wir hier glaube ich an den seiten
diese ja hier in salmünster machen
ich bin in so ein loch gefallen alter
dachte schon das wäre so ende der welt
du kannst du bist haben verdoppelt so
das sieht aber gut aus der verein muss
auf einer höhe mit dem mit dem kopf ins
tor
die ersatzteile von alle zwei minuten
sammler verein hier
verstehst was man ja ich verstehe schon
was du meinst habe ich ja davor einen
fehler gemacht aber hier müssen wir auch
noch ein bisschen weiter
ach ja da vorne da war ich noch nicht da
habe ich auch die sachen schon abgebaut
du willst einfach die sachen nicht mehr
aufgebaut hat so kein ding helfer hast
leider ist er soziale arbeit
wir machen noch ewig gleiche arbeit aber
ich finde glocke hinsetzt macht mehr
spaß als möglich abzubauen ich fühle
mich gerade auch ja finde ich auch ich
fühle mich aber gerade wie so ein
verbrecher irgendwie dir irgendwie seine
strafe abarbeiten ja ich fühle mich auch
so anders gar nichts gemacht gerade wir
haben auch nichts gemacht irgendwie so
richtig wir haben halt immer nur
gekontert ich habe auch nie so richtig
angefangen sondern immer nur so gekonnt
hat halt und jetzt auf einmal sind wieso
die leute die jetzt wieso h bei
gerichten messen und arbeiten müssen die
sonst sozialstunden arbeiter wo es auch
falsch verstanden welt warum arbeitet
ihr denn wer hat euch den gezogen war es
der unter ja es war simon
wir wurden gezwungen nein dann wir
machen das natürlich alles für den guten
zweck der erlös der der der von dem weg
hier aus geht der wird dann kinderdörfer
gespendet
hast du für mich noch diesen komischen
cobblestone natürlich auch deswegen habe
ich davon mitgenommen
dankeschön ich war letztens mit denen
auch sozialen was macht ihr denn nimmt
einfach alle sachen wenn man sozialismus
man endlich seine sache nehmen dann für
die allgemeinheit zu spenden
die dann einfach sachen von simon das
heißt eigentlich 7 und sozialisation
gesetzt der behinderte geilmann werden
wir mal eben schnell sundwig
fertiggemacht bringe jetzt noch mégane 1
oder forderte von ihr die ecke die habe
ich ja falsch gesetzt wir recht wollen
uns allerdings hier hinsetzen sondern
verewigung schild können wir machen
natürlich die anderen noch wissen des
wählers an
okay da weg ist fertig weg ausarbeitung
passt nicht weg aus arbeit
sponsoren und ponys konne hd gmbh so
hatte weg ausarbeitungen sponsort
balkone und conny scon von hdg geiler
erwarte davon einen screenshot
verschlossen
das ist sozial ja er stellt sich direkt
vor mich das ist ein richtiger goma
alter ich sag's mal als krieg ich auch
stellt sich einfach vor mich
stell dich mal so daneben stelle ich
noch so daneben erleben
nee bisschen weiter links von mir aus
gesehen genau perfekt perfekt perfekt
mache ich das dann ja wirklich billig
alter wirklich perfekt alltag leider
screenshot ich mach doch mal bitte ok
start daneben
klaus und coolen screenshot hier
fakten die hier wollen wir den weg noch
mal fertig machen hier aber der stelle
packen wir ewig einfach mal weg machen
oder brauchen wir machen reden wäre
machen resource center das mache also
cent zu hause warten dann brauchst du
eigentlich den zauberstab dann für mich
nicht um den anderen weg richtig ist
einfach so verdiene ich wäre das fett ab
später vorkommt
wo kann man hier dennoch dem ich angst
werden wieder mal ein toller tag
also man könnte man müsse hauptstraße
machen die hauptstraße ist eigentlich da
wo simon ich du wurden so die messe
schön machen
das war jetzt bei ihnen hierzu bei
debitor den mann kommt man der weg von
rewe ich komme gleich machen könnte
zu mir du bist gerade wo ich sehe den
namen okay ich bin sofort bei den weg
hier so so rum fühlt so weiß dass er
hier so weiß was man manchmal machen ja
so dass der so irgendwie so eckig geht
und nicht so verwinkelt nicht sogar
stock und stein
aber es ist doch eigentlich ganz neues
hier mit den ganzen seerosen und die
stars er wolle das ganze natürlich
zivilisiert gestalten soll ich dann eben
einfach koppel machen
da mache ich ganz dass hier gerade ein
bisschen einbricht wie ich den weg zu
machen würde
es passt sogar perfekt so ich brauche
kompendien zuschauer ist cook stefanie
bathe 12 was sind das drei damit noch
noch viel mehr koppel
das heißt einfach mit julia steiner
herstellen warten bis zu warten so ich
möchte mal eben den server dann kannst
du dich schnell verfliegen und ich
restart im moment was ich mache hier
noch immer richtig ist dass die
aufnahmen direkt ist das ist immer so
frustrierend
ich habe eine stunde mit sieben aufgaben
plötzlich der pc an brown alter wir
können einfach meine brücke machen fällt
mir dazu ein
aber in rebstein hallo dass der weg mich
auch wenn wir da so ein fenster und
stiegen ein dass ich nicht schäbig aus
wir machen das ich hab schon eine tolle
idee wie das machen
das sieht auf jeden fall sogar los wie
ich also alle so sehr geil und sei
erkältet ja sehr erkältet ein erkälteter
brücke ich liege in einem bettchen und
jetzt gucken wir mal wieder die nase
muss kurz halten
die halleschen und willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge von mega projekt im
hintergrund hört ihr ein wunderschönes
schnee von crafter ich kann leider
gerade nicht auf dem server seite
ich finde die ganze zeit ich bin ja nur
ganz kurz am mikro so ich guck ganz kurz
aus der kamera weg ich hörte ich
erweitern und seda dem bildschirm
bewegen ich kann nicht sehen dass das
auf kann direkt von meinem grundstück
auf skates grund studenten gucken
megageil megatrucks ist darüber darf und
der uns
das schon gut dann bei uns so ich baue
mir von schüttelt er beinahe fiel ihr
nicht doch habe ich sogar habe ich nicht
um hier gar nichts gar nichts
so wenig hatte auch noch ein bisschen
doch halben stack ganz klar wieso ich
komme wieder rauf auf dem server von
firma okay ich schaue es bei ihm wie das
hier hin wie wir das weiterführen
könnten und zwar
wir können nicht einfach mal ne brücke
machen ja ich das hier wieder ab so moya
gleich bin ich wieder hier weg hier weg
hier weg hier weg hierüber tiere weg
hier weg so geben die brücke dann lange
die ist nicht auf einer höheren ebene
muss noch einen höheren eventure nach
solchen auch wieder da für comcom
zuschauer wie schön die ist die brücke
ist megaschön zweifel so irgendwie
vorhanden
bei mir ist mega viel corporate auch in
den ganzen kisten und so hole ich mir
eben starb ich habe es falsch auf den
ardennen falsche habe ich gebaut so eins
der kajak einer 1 6 1
ja aber in den kisten und sowie viele
thron du allein chance da findet man
sich doch gar nicht zurecht hier
eisenach erst recht ihren 1000 tools
ordentlich koppel
ich bin niemals hell sich gerade in der
felskante ist dass man so ein bisschen
runter zu stellen hier möchte sind da
immer diese face camps bringe nur
probleme zack das war schon ein bisschen
besser also sind hier fehlt den weg hast
du gerade gibt lol überaus einfach mal
mega fette brücke normal alter normal so
machtlos wie stellt sie es vorher genau
welchen etage darunter machen
meinetwegen ihre mutter verloren
ich würde die runterfallen bleibt das so
123 dann kommt da wieder hin und er geht
denn hier so rüber so wenn ihr sodann
123 dann ist hier wieder gut so ich
hoffe du verstehst du dann noch wenn du
hier gleichberechtigt den ring von riva
anschauen
wir haben wahrlich gleichzeitig flieger
lächeln sowieso schwerer fünf menschen
mal auf fünf nehmen haben sie gleich
geschafft so ich geh jetzt einfach mal
hier sehe ich eine etage drunter für
dann hier
doch so ist das richtig
nee was hast du für ein foul im atrium
das aussieht was verfahrwege in einen
weg hier hinten eine abgrenzung ist voll
geil ist der der es mir egal ist halt
dein maul erstmal an
ich mag oder weise ist der weg immer so
zwei breit und bei dir einfach mal hier
435 breit mehr drei breites der jahre
habe ich glaube ich was falsch gefüllt
hier läuft vorbei das kann euch
vallstein ag keiner heran ohne witze
sind eben allein fliegen von daher ist
es voll geil aus ich habe das natürlich
es hat nie auf gerettet so hier muss
jetzt noch hin
du musst du die erde gleich wieder zu
dem machen zu koppeln
was machst du da unten ein boah krass
was ein fachmann mega fetten weg geht
raus normal denn der muss so fett sein
die brücke sieht aber schon geil aus
naja sei mal ehrlich herr okay sie
scheiße aber vorher wie ist diese fünf
paket dann wird das einfach mal so zwei
bereits der machen was ihr 1 2 bereitete
setzt und sie läuft daher brocken fans
ist das egal
so hier noch weg hin
jetzt aber echt mega scheiße
sparkonto special bisschen mehr
vertrauen der eigenen bauten quatsch es
war schön ja die ganzen hausbesitzer
hier wo wir die wege so ersetzt haben
würden sich bei uns rächen weil die das
alles irgendwie toll an sich bevor die
soziale seite die komplett an
ja wir haben der eine reiste meint ihr
das halbe haus ob der andere dann die
gattin der hälfte der eine aber das geht
doch noch voll eigentlich kennt auch
noch gut aus also wenn man jetzt von
ganz oben guckt das ist auf jeden fall
schon mal ein bisschen ja natürlich die
scheiße aus aber das ist ja kein und
hier muss ich die erde ja wie du schon
sagtest ankoppeln verwandeln
ja hier ist uns also eher dahin ja doch
also eine stimmung besteht werden was
auch bestimmt opel denkt da schon der
hundeschule hingeworfen
danke so haben wir das auch schon mal
geschafft so gut dann würde ich sagen
haben wir bisher was soziales zumindest
gemacht wir haben den gegner schon
allerhand wir haben den weg ein bisschen
erweitert wir haben uns gegenseitig
geholfen meint matthew funktioniere ja
richtig und dann würde ich sagen wenn es
euch gefallen hat uns beide eine
beratung sehr freuen wenn ihr mehr
soziale sachen sehen wollt und richtig
wenn ihr denkt dass comedy aller art auf
der welt ist
oder konkreter ja das bin ich ja ehe das
wissen die ja schon
also ja vielleicht kannst du dir auch
weil ein tut mir leid
ach du wirklich die allerletzte seinem
kompletten planet okay jetzt auch
geklärt
wir sehen uns dann irgendwann in einer
anderen folge wieder die kommt bei mir
dann die tage oder morgen oder keine
ahnung und dann damit ich dann
hoffentlich hoffentlich wieder gesund
hoffentlich kann ich zwar auch noch mal
gute besserung